ce n'est pas d'elle c'est bay 9 choquant
m
la map un jour way to do with tantôt de
france abat une paye qu'on ne s'est pas
vu c'est ce que ça veut dire daïna oui
petit canard farci seul fabien flore
nurse assez gonflé vanasse est gonflé on
va dire non ça veut dire bienvenue en
malgache c'est vrai ça veut dire plein
d'autres ça veut dire guerre en russe
combat en hébreu cocaïne savoir cocaïne
entre l'ont bien
malgré les avis sans passeport que ces
tampons de la colombe et ses manies
finir fourreau de clèves dire au stick
cause de petits pois ces fouilles dans
toutes les langues c'est à dire quelque
chose génitales en charbon qu'on va vite
venu ici c'était pour un film vous
faisait l'amour sur un solex
elias a relancé la production de solex
j'ai pas le droit c'est vrai on vend des
solex à tire larigot de même partout pas
que la wii alors on est ici ce soir pour
la sortie en salles après canal+ c'est
le dvd d'un film intitulé nuit noire 17
octobre 1961 c'était un film d'alain
tasma scénario de patrick rotman avec
tout il de kuro jean michel portal atmen
kelif thierry fortineau et vous
le résumé du film c'est simple c'est l'
affaire papon 2 voilà automne 1961 la
guerre d'algérie a franchi la
méditerranée
le 5 octobre le préfet de police maurice
papon décrète la fermeture des débits de
boissons à 19 heures pour les français
musulmans d'algérie donc s'instaure une
espèce de couvre-feu le fln à ce moment
là organisent une manifestation qui est
interdite mais qui se déroule quand même
le soir du 17 octobre des milliers de
personnes sont arrêtées et des cadavres
seront repêchés dans la seine voilà donc
c'est une histoire dont on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé par ton qui est incarné
par thierry fortineau dit dans le film
pour un coup reçu vous en rendrez 10
dans tous les cas vous serez couvert
voilà donc c'est un secret d'état d'une
certaine façon qui a été très peu
divulguée jusqu'à ces dernières années
on va regarder d'abord à quoi ça
ressemble à prendre en par vous et
regardez votre caméra vous allez dire
magnéto serge khalfon